I leave in are you on your way back home
either way we wanna be there doesn't
matter how much baggage you give us time
and made terminal and gate we wanna send
you off inside we wanna welcome you back
home tell us all about it we scared or
was it fine now horn
do you need a ride do you need a ride
do you need a ride do you need a ride do
you need with Karen and Chris
come to do you need a ride this is Chris
Fairbanks just Karen Cole Garrett we're
driving westbound on Santa Monica
Boulevard my place having cement pillars
there's a lot going on guys and in the
back seat we have a guest special guest
this week special because he's one of my
oldest friends but not dearest so that's
a special situation it doesn't happen
that often
oftentimes we start the podcast with a
thinly-veiled
would almost sound like an insult it's
kind of 90s comedy we we have a guest
today that's not a dear friend that's
the 90s comedy uppercut oh yeah yeah
that he and I are used to yeah the old
one-two punch with an edge that's right
wouldn't you say dearest friend is
overrated anyway yeah holy that my dear
friend all that means is it's a lot of
like boring times yeah puzzle I see just
at the doorway of somebody's house going
like that was really nice I'm so glad we
did that okay well I guess I might see
you tomorrow then
yeah and if you don't if you die first
know that you were dear to me
it always smells like doilies in here
we're talking about grandmas yeah yeah
in front of Grandma my grandma's are the
dearest but that's not who it is
no and gentlemen it's Fred Armisen Fred
Armisen hi everybody
karen was right I've known Karen for a
very long time and yeah how long how
long since details mm maybe mm actually
is it I think it's mm that's when I
first moved to LA and in that year is
when I started going to Largo so I would
say mm maybe 2001 but I actually think
it's 2000 because I was gonna say 89
that's weird
what year was it Fred when you went to a
dance place and took dance classes like
tap glances and classes and made a video
of it that was in 1998 okay I remember
that yeah I did that in 1998 so it's
weird I've known Fred longer than you
know just let's see I equate the
internet watching a video as a
friendship but it is a friendship it is
because I'm so shallow I'm so thin in
personality that that's all that matters
to me if people watch your videos yeah
that's that's all I need to know yeah
I've got lots of friends and Chris I I I
guess I performed with you in a
Bumbershoot yeah I don't know if we were
on the same show but we were certainly
in the same venue during the same
weekend that's and that's in Seattle is
where that happens yes yes and a lot of
people mistakenly say bumpers shoot boy
are they wrong yeah it's bumbershoot
with a bee
even exist anymore I think it does I
asked exactly the same question it does
it's going it's going great
they have comedians there I'm sure they
all enjoy it just we aren't invited
oh I see oh that's fine I had my time
there but Mary I had my time there as
well I was a great wait now it's like we
can actually go back and do a reunion
that's how long it's been
that's right the year you were in it and
I was in it also with Flight of the
Conchords popped up it Marc Maron
you there's some other big you wait
let's let's go back to the hood is the
flight of the conchords yes hello all
right nice all right
okay who's the next one it was Marc
Maron hey that's the why I'm shaking you
know I can't do a minute I'm taking the
gene wallet no I can't do it yeah I
can't no dude you're 40 yeah 40 man
forty grown up I'm a grown man that's
all I got Martin do me tomorrow no I'm
gonna just 40 hmm why there's two
there's two here now there's three ah
but that's the same one was TIG there
that year I don't know want to give up
sometimes you know that's it that's all
I will see there Jackie Mason Oh
I think I could do Nick talking about
the night before oh look a walk-up okay
that's it thank you thank you very much
very good friend when TIG and I had a
cat I'd live with take for a while and
we had a cat and then Nick came up with
that totally about this where the cat
was sick and its face was swollen and
take and I neither of us had money and I
was really worried about and Nick had
money and he said well I'll take the cat
to the bed and he came over and he
looked at the cat he's and and they turn
around he farted on my cat's head it
just farted in the cat's face to where
the cat reacted and then he said your
cat has feline AIDS and then which I
really fallen on the couch he farted on
the cat's face and then and then decided
that the cat had AIDS
that's what's true favorite joke but
then the cat did end up dying of AIDS
Feli name he was right in his diagnosis
it was a few years later and I'm not
saying that's funny but it was at the
time I think feline AIDS is definitely
funny it was missed that cats a cat you
will not see ever see a cat laughing at
that or at anything what's terrible what
that fart is that animals you know cats
don't understand human language but that
is one piece of language they understand
that it like Italy really insulted by
like a smell and a sound like that is
like that's like the one bridge to
animals yeah communication that I know
we get I get the better that's an inner
speciall insult their species speciall
right Aaron knows where the fart is
everyone gets odor yeah shooting odor at
someone is like
our animals across the world they're
like oh we get it there's no animal
culture where that said that reaction
that can also I saw them walk into a
spiderweb once and acted like a human
like he went and looked at his modesty
if there's a spider on him he was like
oh no and he he was a gifted he was a
gifted cat that's the only in that
situation is where all animals in their
head say god damn it even cats
everyone's cursed at by spiderwebs no
one likes them so Fred you know you were
recently in South America yes I was in
Colombia what were you doing shooting an
episode of documentary now oh cool we
did like a jiro Dreams of Sushi thing of
a gex or Colombian food one yes yeah I
would say it's more like chef's table I
love chef scene yeah it's pretty great
cook that thing with the wood is that
the one here there's one I saw where
they cut something in dirt some buried
the Argentinian guy yes buried food I
was like what does this guy do
look he didn't look South American right
like a white guy yeah I love that one
yeah Wow yeah that's so cool yeah so
that was really nice the ground like a
kiln Ursula yeah it's sort of the way to
fire over it well I mean I you know
maybe they just did it for the cameras
they're like let's pretend like we do
this oh yeah we bury it and so I left by
the way we're passing the Hollywood
Forever Cemetery yes where Johnny Ramone
is buried it's got a really
statue they're teeny Ramona's here as
well there's also I would think they'd
be in New York aren't this anymore yeah
but you know how like New Yorkers are
like they all want to go to like Miami
or California you know to die I'm gonna
do my thing with a palm trees you know
yeah I'm gonna do my upper my torso West
Coast my legs East Coast oh good idea
just ashes just please everybody oh
you're gonna split it up sure
ashes are just that the actual torso
like you're gonna leave it like that's a
better idea you're right maybe you
should do that just taxidermy them don't
just go split yourself Lingle why you're
right everyone should getting equal i'm
symmetrical let's take advantage of that
yeah it's right down the middle
full body part like a tapeworm yeah okay
i'm gonna do an open casket and it's
gonna be just the torso and it'll be
like like what what's the problem my
confrontational art like that's what
death looks like yeah look at it it'll
be a recording of you saying that they
don't play as people pass i might hire
an actor that's right oh and then you
can sit in the audience and watch yes
I've got my skull give your own eulogy
yeah in South America you speak Spanish
well don't you
my mom is Venezuelan so I speak Spanish
oh yeah I heard you at the taco truck
yeah I knew what your I was showing off
were you yeah were you doing Castilian
bliss I skipped it I think I went right
for tacos porfavor
yeah every step but then he started
asking really specific questions and I I
got lost but what is the expiration date
on that man in town yes like that yes
she seemed very frustrated she
clearly hated but you have to do no
chase Kong plantain eat oh I know I want
to do that I really do it you what what
is it
it is a show that I still don't know why
I was asked but it's a Spanish speaking
I think very popular in South America
even more so than Mexico but also Mexico
and it's a there Jimmy Fallon type show
and the set and everything looks like
regular talk-show but the host has clown
makeup yeah and a pink wig but he's very
funny and I he shaved my mustache during
the show that was my idea but he shaved
it into a part in a Hitler mustache
sorry how was it how was it how does
that's a hard thing to shave somebody I
keep I know but then he said Oh Charlie
Chaplin it was fine everything was fine
it was an American show it says there
was a fuchsia it was it took place here
in Los Angeles but the viewers of it are
mostly in Mexico and so it's all the
lines are getting blurry Canon it's all
getting like don't like it and their
sushi here and not in Japan I just
interrupted you from it's ok I'm sorry
no it's ok
the what about sushi in Japan just the
how the lines are all getting blurry
it's exactly you can have sushi here you
can have sushi you know in Italy it's
gonna have a hamburger on a fishing boat
info bye it happens we're going up
towards Sunset Boulevard yeah I love LA
so much for real I really do
I've always loved it and for some reason
I feel like Sunset Boulevard is like the
center that's like the kind of Main
Street of LA well it's and it goes all
the way through east side of the West
Side
all the way oh yeah I feel like I don't
even live here cuz I live at the dumb
beach yeah that's right all the way out
we have Fred now when you lived here and
you would go to Sunset Boulevard what
was looks like the first place you think
of that you would go to the mean streets
of Sunset Boulevard like when I first
moved here and stuff sure um I remember
somewhere in-between like where amoeba
is and like that whole ask is at cbiit
summer
ivar sunset i right sunset in Ivar yes I
would you went straight to Ivar seafood
restaurant and then as it dips into like
Silver Lake and all that it's just
that's a nice feeling you know a little
places you can get breakfast yeah I like
it and then and then going west I like
it when you just end up in Beverly Hills
you're like by the hotel and everything
it's a it's a higher cut of person maybe
more maybe foreign maybe they're from
you know China or maybe they're of Saudi
no Karen said a higher set higher higher
it's fun to pretend racism it's
pretending it's only pretend it's
pretend it's like it's like bubble it's
like blah blah or demons what is it it's
our it's like exercise exercising yeah
yeah uh-huh
that's what podcasting is all about I
mean chasing away any real thoughts that
maybe would have
like that but they don't hey while we're
doing this really quick everyone out
there was sitting listen to podcasts get
out there get a listen please you know
we do this for free yeah people should
start getting paid for it get out there
tell your friends that there's a podcast
out there for everybody any buck you
know and if you like it rate it on
iTunes what's Fred what's her favorite
podcast yeah there's one called the trap
set and it's a drummer who interviews
other drummers but he loves it yeah it's
this drummer who interviews at the drum
but there are no drums in the room so
it's not like people show off what they
can do they just talk about what their
experience is and it's really cool it's
very oh yeah
and who's the host this this guy named
Joe Wong that's his name and he was in a
band he's been he's been in a number of
bands but he has a really nice voice and
he's just really good at interviewing
people very calm
yes very calm asks people about their
experiences and he doesn't get all hyped
up and crazy right right
like morning zoo radio nothing like that
and he also doesn't do duo's which is
like the worst way to do a podcast my
traffic record us comparing it to me
already talking about
and I were saying we need some tough
love we haven't had any of them yeah we
just got some get on the show now when
you are on a show like that a drumming
show do you do since there aren't drums
to be able end up playing their chest
the way drummers love to do mmm boo doo
bah and stuff like that no it's it it
all is like what are your influences who
did you use to listen to who did you
want to be and what is your drum set
like and where you know what's it like
dealing with bass players like that kind
of thing so if you don't play drums
maybe it would be like my future
skateboarding podcast kind of boring
right if you know what for drummers they
love it okay of course you know they
love it
don't like that's so such a specific
audience yeah I like that I like that
it's so specific with yeah I'm gonna do
a skateboarding yeah I was almost gonna
make a joke like it's not for fans of
blank like I was to think of a
teenybopper band yeah I am you could
instantly like age yourself by like what
reference you use and I don't know the
right reference right I don't anymore
you don't mean like I don't have that
person to go like it's not like a blank
podcast like I don't know who did bring
up and I can't even think of the one
that would work now I don't even know if
it doesn't know we don't generate don't
know whatever little there is out there
there's a reference that someone would
be like you guys why didn't you say
blank yeah I don't know it's a it's a
band called blank yeah we've never heard
I really really don't know you can see
Zac Efron I think he's like couldn't win
an Oscar soon if you can't
you know who would know it's like my
niece my sister my niece for Halloween
last year was one of the girls in a show
on
I think the Disney Channel called
descendants or something
uh-huh but I know that as a band and I
know that as like a couple other things
so I was like sorry what did she dress I
thought it was weirdest band
no I think I've heard this before I
think I've heard this is a reference
before and you're right I was like this
is the joke I'm doing these days he's
not my logos to college descendent no
it's something else
yeah and it's also not the movie not the
new the movie from four years ago
remember
it's little girls with kind of Madonna
style lace in their hair and black nail
polish kinda like doing stuff I'm not
even sure what they do yeah it's
something specifically you would not
mention on the drumming podcast no never
but I mean to have it be so popular she
dressed up as it for Halloween and I did
not know it's not a weird feeling you
know like I've officially don't know
what this is because I'm we're growing
up you the stuff that you liked was
adult because there weren't things
specifically for kids really for like
the game operation and a couple other
things all right it was like five things
yeah and we all shared that we have
we're forced to yeah share things we
didn't even like yeah
Fred you ever go to the 99-cent store
when you lived in LA I think I went in
there once thinking I could maybe
something for like pots and pans kind of
thing and I did not like it I was very
like it was a fine place I don't mean to
say anything bad about you but I there's
nothing that I wanted I made the mistake
of getting a bag of limes there do not
buy produce at table you good looking
for canned goods and then and some new
type of for always I took Spanish in
college nice and then and but don't get
any Duncan any produce yeah that would
mix it was bad lines but while we're on
this let's talk a little about college
apply college and tell your friends you
never know all over the country you get
it it's it is the best graduate school
junior whatever kind of college even you
know apply to an Ivy League one you
never know you don't know [ __ ] students
they can meet students just like you
need to learn so mention what I know
about financial aid application that's
another that's another level but it's
easy you fill out a thing and then go
okay we'll get it we're gonna give you
your education for free here's how much
my parents make and you can lie yeah
they make five dollars they go great is
free money because then you get smart
and you go work for the government or
whatever everyone wins
yeah get out there get out there what if
there was a podcast I know what you
everything you need is now in college I
would call it drip for prep for college
that big entitled cold : spelled out
that's a long podcast so that we have a
lot of talking again some people will
take like seven years so much to cover
yeah
if you took winter off to go skiing
especially if you ever fred living if
for reals in portland is that a dumb
question no it's not a dumb question i
yeah don't ask me that
no I I I'm there every summer and I've
been there every summer for the last you
know whatever six years or something so
so in a way yeah I mean there for quite
a few months so the show's it's the show
hasn't been on quite six years oh yeah
oh yeah Oh can't we just this is the
sixth season just I know it feels like
yesterday for me for me it does it feels
no woman very quickly yeah it's done so
you wouldn't live there already for a
little while before no no I I'd been
there a lot yeah when we started doing
the show then I started staying there uh
it would be so fun to have an excuse
like anytime a job comes up we get to
move to a place that isn't LA or New
York it's so fascinating to me
right I love that idea where it's almost
like you get to go and just live in a
normal town with normal people you don't
see what that's like for a while I agree
and then you also if it's enough time
you kind of get to know it a little bit
so that if anyone ever says to you hey
I'm from this place you can actually say
with some confidence oh yeah I know what
that's like you could even say to them I
know more about it than you do right
which is a fun conversation stranger
yeah yeah yeah cuz then they're like
listen to the snow at all I think yeah
I'd like to challenge people I know I
need them you know originally was the
capital and it wasn't a city stage did
you know that and the dollar bill was
designed there did you know that
confronted this way first basketball
game was played here did you know that
is you know I'd like that state justly
like by the beach there it's almost
tropical Thursday it's so green and
there's ferns it's just the best day to
be in Portland yes Oregon in general
very lush it's very like myself please I
feel like my skin is
being actively rehydrated when I'm there
I feel like I'm breathing for the first
time and I cross the total line I also
feel kind of safe I'm like I don't think
anything it doesn't seem dangerous right
now and there's a lot of ladies and
clouds which I respect and it makes me
feel at home
fleece and clogs you never get that in
LA now clogs are they always real wood
soles um well if you get dance Co which
are the quality ones oh yes
that's gonna happen don't settle for
some of those other plastic clogs right
right now we're near the Vista let's all
tell experience if we have them of Mines
we went to the Vista I saw van helsing
there and almost had my ears blown out
of it was so loud and sharp
do you remember Danny Cevallos of course
um I was there with Danny Cevallos and I
stood up in the middle of movie and said
I will not stay here anymore this is
insane and I was so angry about how loud
the movie was I all could I can I'll go
next I went what there's a movie with
Halle Berry
I think it's called gothic it was
horrible hmm I saw it there gal gothic
Attica never my eyes identica they know
what Scott yeah gothic IRA goth
yeah yeah and it was kind of a scary
movie and there was a drip in the
ceiling and things were happening and I
would feel these drips and it was coming
from the ceiling and I also wanted leave
cuz I was horrified during the movie
you're getting dripped on it was raining
it then there were strips and then
within my popcorn these strips it's not
good so there at the end
afraid to have a positive there's a
story to help this out
I can't remember any movies I've seen
there I just remember one time I shot a
little music video with Charlene ye in
the front of it mm-hm
so my met my memory of it is now just it
on video like I heard that how that
looked and it looks so nice
but as far as walking out of a movie
come on guy whose car that doesn't
belong to him there's a siren just for
people listening there are many many
fire engines many many there are all
these cars and ambulances the ambulance
drivers are bloody something really
terrible happened well drive the other
way it seemed really horrible the
ambulances were on fire they're gonna
call that the sunset but the sunset
bloodbath they're gonna call it that oh
I can feel it it was Harlow hello I
can't take this call right now oh hello
1981 time at the Chinese Theatre what's
up grant Grauman's yeah I went to see
Lord of the Rings with Bob Odenkirk and
we both went and it I don't I never had
the books I don't know anything about it
and all of a sudden we both realized we
didn't know what's going on so I was I
was like what happened there's a river
and there's a ring dropped in and I was
really it was too much for me and then I
was hope I didn't know that Bob felt the
same way and he was like what
but I love movies storm out I don't know
why I read it I have loved it it's a
very like I don't have to stand up to do
this exactly right you can't take my
life away from me I did that in like
water for elephants or whatever that
Robert Robert Pattinson Kristen
we saw this wonderful chocolate know
there's an elephant yeah it was more
reciting remember that I think that like
a circus movie an elephant one is a
better exchange for some water
yeah then just some chocolate your honor
for a fat carry on
it's a really powerful feeling to do
that yeah you're kind of tearing up $13
but you're also saying I don't accept
this you can't do this to me I don't I
can't think of a movie I walk down on
I thought sit and watch something even
if I'm not enjoying it
I think I'm lazy that way my I can enjoy
bad movies but then if a movie isn't
it's bad bad is it good bad that I'm out
of there oh yeah I walked out on the
Beatles The Beatles one where it's like
kids doing Beatles karaoke oh yes across
the interval across the university I was
afraid I did not enjoy that I don't know
understand what was happening in that I
know it was children singing I did I
just it was like karaoke I yeah I
remember that I never saw it but what
happened like was it like people just
reenact think some of their songs or
something yes it was like a rock opera
is that I think it was I think so yeah
storyline with these kids that you don't
care about just a gaggle of Zac Efron's
and then people were very Efron asked
yeah they're very F Ronny it's when
we're f Ronny movies for him and not
being in a lot of Beatles music but at
none of that by the Beatles which I
didn't realize till then is a
prerequisite for me enjoying the Beatles
is it
having to be then yeah yeah did you grow
up on the Beatles in Missoula I sure did
yeah my parents really shoved those
beetles down my throat a lot of beetles
and a lot of jazz my mom like very
frenetic what I call flippy toe jazz the
kind that made me nervous and like I
like running errands
flippy topaz
no friend have you ever been in a jazz
band and all your gear I've never been
in a jazz band I'm not a fan of jazz
drumming oh I'm so glad you said that
that's right and I'm not either it's too
just like woman's ago and my kid never
it's on purpose won't do a beat hmm so
I'm like you is there a reason you don't
want to hit anything that's in a row
it's like I need some you know that's
what I hired you for drugs yeah that's
why I bought this record so here's some
drums people have called me the jazz
drummer of comedy because I'm like that
joke say never tell them the same and
they don't always quite hit how do you
guys know each other
it was the one who made up Chris's title
the jaws drummer of comedy yeah yeah and
then he confronted me on it one night
yeah and I just brought it up just now I
think we made friends through Greg
Behrendt
yeah I think when I very first came here
and just visited
stayed with Howard Kramer because I
started in Austin so I'm kind of an
Austin comedian and I met you at of
laundry at Lucy's laundromat oh right
but we weren't friends told me a handful
of years later yeah that's right
remember those shows that Lucy's doesn't
good they were I remembered the having
visit I was visiting and went to one and
it did scare me about the future of me
doing comedy in LA because I thought
that all I was going to be doing is
shows where there's people not up paying
attention while they're folding their
socks in the background I thought that
was gonna be all comedy I always thought
that surprising people I thought that
part was upsetting until I would get on
stage and then realized that was
actually the fun part we were like
watching a young mother just trying to
shirt I would have there and take her
laundry and go and then she would seed
them like start to titter and then
you're like I did my job it's a
different job than normal but I did it
yeah I guess I would like it now maybe
so we go back and perform should we do
it right now I mean it would be the same
as the show was back when there was an
organized people were asked to go there
but for some reason maybe the people who
are folding laundry that's how they
enjoyed comedy shows so if we went back
they'd be like oh we know what you're
doing thank you for bringing it back
are you still doing the same bits like
they kinda know some of them are you
looking at your notes still it's funny
your mom's from Venezuela so what you
see yeah so I you can do that accent but
I felt very uncomfortable doing the
welcome to it just like the same thing
with accents from India everyone I'm
getting uncomfortable about thinking
about someone doing it oh don't do any
an accent Hank Azaria looking at you
don't know why I'm gonna skate on that
no thread yes Karen you also were in
France Wow yes I was working private
news I was for the air I was in I was
working in Italy and
and you're at your restaurant the pasta
place yeah you know that was like a dig
sounds like a little bit of a dig guys
and I love it
and and then I just took a little trip
to Paris I hadn't been there since I was
a little kid boy what a nice place
pretty good right
it's really good it's such a cliche just
to say how beautiful it is but it really
was those buildings are incredible
is it clean they're like yeah it's just
cool a lot of people peeing everywhere
huh no really nice it like looks like
you're it looks like Europe and but like
polished and nice their fancy their
fancy people yeah
does it seem like they have a handle on
men Poland like you don't see mentally
ill folks running around like in America
I'm guessing oh they take care of their
people I imagine that I was probably in
the areas where you just don't see stuff
yeah sure and I mean like I'm sure sure
you know I always imagine that I don't
know if they still have social services
yeah it's a good idea yep you should
have them for people yes
but the mental health issue in Shanghai
and China is huge and anyone out there
listening it it's a huge deal in
Shanghai please anything you could do to
tell people that there's a mental health
issue in Shanghai please the issue is
that it's going to well that there are
no that no one has mental health issues
there oh so we should be jealous we
should be jealous but it's upsetting
there's the ones that have been Shanghai
yeah sometimes I do just classic jokes
like that that's why I mean it like a
really deep yeah yeah yeah I'm the one
that's been Shanghai and then I make a
face that yes
unnoticed on podcast yeah no they could
hear it your cheese cracking
we mugged it up there sounded like
popcorn are you HOT yeah well no it's
just getting like why is it getting so
foggy I think cuz we're here at the
ocean why does it get foggy near the
ocean I think when a cold front and oh I
give up and a warm front yes that's it
love each other very much water pressure
vapor then what vaporizes what but what
a pressure does why well right it goes
up alright I think which is so why is
that like condensation because because
it's wet because it's heavy and that
comes back down I like that's my heavier
yeah because heavier than what and
that's how hot water balloon works
and please please remember to throw hot
water balloons as much as you can if you
see something say something right yeah
not about we don't see that enough no
like to where you're like oh no that's
and that's like oh that was body
temperature thank you yeah oh I was
thinking scalding like it's a prank
doesn't already have a prank of throwing
a hot water in the leather skin hanging
off sorry I was hit with a scalding hot
water balloons sorry sorry I'm late
scalding hot water in the description of
it is so it's so about human pain you
know it's the only thing extremely hot
or boiling it's like this was will scald
you yeah
scalding it's hot one it's like scalding
it's the yeah it's the only describes
that one thing like the word full-blown
only inscribes of course and yeah water
balloons no I was still talking about
sorry I guess yeah I know I guess you're
right people say it about it that is
true when is gonna say a full blown hot
water balloon yeah
full blown full blown air balloon full
blown tire Hey right there's a lot of
difference yeah it doesn't just have to
be AIDS okay I retract my statement oh
we know you guys aren't really doing
anything they're like this is pull some
cable up yeah and just watch some Street
we just watched some Street workers yeah
oh yeah I always forget yeah big yellow
vest oh yeah remember that from five do
you guys love that movie falling down
yes I like that when they got mad at the
construction workers I think about that
scene in a movie more than you know cuz
I'm quick to anger which I never saw it
undermine you know me to be very angry
but you'd never shoot know why random
people on the freeway I keep my anger
deep I spend it on myself until the
right person comes along and so I
haven't met anyone yet you know who's
very angry it's Fred oh yeah we're a
negative man um I'm an angry angry
person she's kidding you seem super
positive is that do people accuse you of
being positive all the time
well did he seem like he must scripture
one of the first
sure do like that thank you
well I know Scripture is a very
nerve-racking word did you go to church
when you were young but barely a little
yeah we're your parents Church not
really not not at all I mean what we're
kind of we kind of went as a family for
a little while and it just fizzled out
we just all of a sudden weren't going
anymore just you all were like over it
yeah we're like done it I we went at
last we get it Todd if ever I ain't got
interested in a youth group in high
school because it was a free meal on
Wednesdays which for some reason that
was a day that was hard for me to Afghan
i real i'm not kidding and then there's
pretty girls there that from school that
i otherwise never would talk to so i
went for the wrong reasons but then got
caught up in all that all the you know
the doing stuff work camps mmm-hmm
prints away I first went to Oregon and
it was really fun but they never stopped
if they ever stopped and said hey have
you read this Bible and all that I would
have been like oh no not really I'm
sorry do I believe now they didn't care
no that's good yeah it was a real low
pressure situation that's how they do it
yeah tell the guys how they get you I
have a saying attract with honey is that
you're saying that yeah
I think I've heard it you're a good
driver Karen you really though yeah
and good have you noticed at Malta and
being able to talk and drive I I told
Fred I'd freeze up well when you're
driving yeah when you're driving it's a
very like you can actually if you were
being interviewed
it's very disarming you know because
you're you're very much of your real
self when you're driving that's ham yeah
it's like a truth snare a lot of people
have admitted to committing crimes on
our podcast because they're how we'll
ask you the question Fred yeah I was
committed a crime recently what oh it
worked
let's hear it I sold I saw I had a house
here when we sold it moved into a new
one right hey the deal called the deal
the house closed that when I sold on
this one day but then the tenants aren't
in yet but I had an extra key so they
were like will you give them the extra
key I was like how am I gonna do this
and I really was trespassing
I used my own kid to get in I trespass
into literally someone else's home I
technically that was not my house nor
did I have permission and I dropped off
the key
and lastly did you take anything there
was nothing in there empty house nothing
to take but you did trespass around a
little bit before you left no ma'am I
was paranoid about it because I was like
this is actually not allowed but it was
the only most efficient it was the most
efficient way to do it
it was the right thing to do like that's
the safe way to get a Curie so you open
the door went in put the key in unless
yeah no one no one else's belongings
were in there right there see well what
can you put the key like under the door
well that didn't fit there's no there's
nothing like that there's no like you
know mail slot or anything like that it
was like a sealed door couldn't have
done kind of in done Wow in the way also
in the way that I would have wanted it
to I wanted just up on the counter yeah
you know I recently know I have
permission never mind
I did the same thing but I took a old
washer and dryer that I bought five
years ago I haven't lived in the house
for that long mm-hmm and the house was
for sale and I saw the washer and dryer
in a picture or take sent it and said
look with this house now and I'm like
there's washer and dryer so I got in
there through the realtor and took my
washer and dryer without talking to the
new owners that just the the home was in
escrow so I did commit a crime yeah you
may take that simply yourself who owned
it who owned the Washington I don't even
know and I don't care this is my watch
retire I bought it and I and they would
never the old renters would not ever
reply to my calls and requests to open
it up my washer/dryer they was holding
it hostage and using it so you got it I
did get it but the joke's on me because
it tears all my underwear apart the
dryer hmm I hate some of the things I've
said on this episode I didn't realize
that was going nowhere just about torn
on your where I feel bad because I did
you at did you want to ask me anything
like interviewee yeah yes friend yeah
when you first when you saw how you were
CGI'd in Zoolander - mm-hmm did you say
to yourself this is the best acting that
I've done or did you say the computer
was acting for me I I felt like now I
have fused and merged with technology so
we as a Bionic entity mm-hmm together we
performed I performed with technology
and was your character supposed to be a
child or did you have a disease that
made you very small my character was
supposed to be a child okay I think the
line he says is I'm 11 or whatever right
yeah that's right yeah I wasn't sure if
that was the name of the disease yeah
that was not the name of it yeah Chris
any interview question right well I
didn't see Jim Zoolander - can it be
about something else yeah it should be
[ __ ] okay what's Carrie Brownstein like
she's she's cool
she's a purist yeah she is intelligent
mm-hmm funny
yes definitely
from punk rock school sure she is a
dedicated friend I'm Adan's I'm not
gonna use dearest friend because I've
never started this whole thing about
something and that'll be that would be
and she's very to the point you know
she's she didn't know shakeout yeah and
I wish I had one of those better words
you know what I mean like I don't want
to say like if lluvias yeah she's a
fluffiness she's she's bellicose she's
bellicose Wow I don't know those words
I don't really know they mean they're
just words I remember for me
oh she's a she's a great person and she
litigious I just Sheila TX that means
you'd like to sue that means she's like
your old uncle oh I thought it'd have
trouble breathing
she funky funky is she how funky is she
on the funk scale of Hillary Clinton to
Parliament Wow
she's right up there with Parliament is
she up there yeah at Vimy Parliament in
England
thank you very much Fred Armisen thank
you I did thank you very much thank you
oh thank you thank you interview
questions do you want to ask us yeah yes
um Chris yes do you think you will
always live in Venice no I don't I'm
getting very close to feel I feel like
it's affecting it's prolonged the amount
of time it's taken for me to get as
happy as I am now I think I would it's
my career is taking a longer
because of Venice because I've lived so
far away and I stay over there and I'm
not hitting the bricks every night
mm-hmm
but I do like wakin up there I like
being by the ocean there's something as
a human I like being by that air so do I
want to be happy during the day or
productive at night does anyone have an
answer but we'll leave it at that
yeah you have two dogs it's true um do
you do they roam wherever they want in
the house like up on couches and beds or
are they like do they have like
designated areas are basically the house
is theirs and I hang out in their house
and I'm gonna back it up by saying and I
think it's almost a problem there's one
piece of furniture available in the
house and it belongs to the dogs
yeah well there's a couple chairs I
believe I live simply so others may
simply live yeah I would I would say a
borderline monastic life in my home and
the dogs just the dogs are just having a
great time
my one dog George has eaten a whole
couch so I didn't want to get another
one it looks like after Heathcliff eats
a fish and there's just bones but it's a
couch to buy for a cheap couch with some
fabric draped over the side of it that's
the best I've really learned to let go
of earthly possessions Wow
yeah do your dogs have learned not to
let go of earthly possessions no my dogs
have learned to do whatever the [ __ ]
they want to grab on to them yeah
they're just it's there it's there of
worlds I'm kind of like an L a parent
with my dogs they just get to do
whatever they want and I sit and pretend
like they're not doing it I respect that
approach I've seen you discipline them
when they run outside and into the baby
but lady was walking a baby in a
stroller and the dog just ran up like a
four-year-old to lick all the best
that's fun to remember well Frank do you
have anything you want to plug I feel
like this one quickly and yet I don't
feel like there's still an air of
mystery about you maybe that's good and
I'll tell everyone out there get out
there be mysterious get out there do
your mysterious thing tell your friends
are you going keep it going
it's a good idea what are your upcoming
and when is documentary now come out or
what's your idea for awhile I mean we
have some more to shoot I watched one
with haters that was I didn't it was
based on the sisters
there's the mo yeah from what's yeah it
was great I was so funny
funny he fell through no I'm just happy
to be here I'm happy to see you guys
thank you thanks for waiting thanks for
my poison and you become our taco truck
yeah he got tacos right before yeah he's
just I'm letting them get cold and
you're you have them in your pocket
we're gonna eat them right now that's
how we're gonna end the podcast yeah
it's Taco Time
what do they filled with cat food school
I took a bite out of my sandwich you
know was cat for those men thought it
was a prank my mom played but then I got
home and there's a can of deviled ham
right by the cats and dish she just
mixed him up yeah but I can't fit my
friends thought my mom was real funny
it's good a good prank it is a good one
but it was non purpose for being on our
program thank you and here's the prank I
did on you guys I disconnected my mic at
the beginning of the interview I still
would have been able to salvage the room
Mike do you need a ride you've been
listening to do you need a ride
way bad either way we wanna be there
doesn't matter how much baggage you give
us time and a terminal
we want to send you love inside we wanna
welcome you back home tell us all about
it we scared her was it fine now horn
do you need a ride do you need a mine do
you me ride do you need a ride do you
need with Karen and Chris
you